[Music]
i made a bad mistake
instead of sitting down i should have
stood up and walked back got in my car
and drove back
to my house and you can quibble about
the guidelines et cetera et cetera but
the spirit
of what i'm preaching all the time was
contradicted
california governor gavin newsom on the
defense after defying his own covet 19
restrictions and attending a dinner
party at an upscale restaurant
with two of the state's top medical
officials photos show the attendees
without masks despite the governor's
statewide mass mandate
well the hypocrisy could cost newsom his
title my next guest says he is seriously
considering challenging newsom in 2022.
san diego mayor
kevin faulconer joins me now mayor
welcome to the show
so what do you make of gavin newsom's
actions and his apology
well good morning uh and i will tell you
it's incredibly hypocritical
and that's what makes so many
californians angry
at a time when people are being asked to
sacrifice
one of the worst economic recessions
ever to have the governor not practice
what he preaches to go to one of the
most lavish expensive restaurants in the
entire country and break
his own rules and executive orders um
that's not leadership
we need new leadership in sacramento we
need a governor that can actually bring
people together
because that's what we need right now
are you concerned at all that the
reaction of california residents will be
to now say well you know what i'm not
doing it i'm not going to wear a mask
i'm not going to socially be socially
distant if he's not doing it why should
i have to do it
well i am and so many so many other
folks are as well i mean
look and i've been out front a lot
encouraging people to do the right
thing to wear that mask practice good
you know hygiene social distancing
because we're all in this together we
want
everybody to be safe but when the
governor doesn't follow
his own orders um it makes people not
want to follow them in that lack of
confidence
it's this whole idea that it's rules for
you but not for him
i think it's not only is it hypocritical
but it works
against what we're trying to do here in
california in san diego county and up
and down the state
which is keep everybody healthy it is a
difficult time
and that's why leadership is so
incredibly important
particularly as we're going into the
holidays and thanksgiving
we need leadership that demonstrates by
example
yeah you know i think people are getting
increasingly tired of politicians not
practicing what they preach just quickly
do you feel that people will be holding
governor newsom accountable for these
actions in terms of
perhaps voting for someone else next
time around uh
i do i think california's need to change
it's it's not just a recent example of
the hypocrisy but
there's so many issues in california
that are not being solved
i mean as we look to our schools haven't
been safely reopened and we're not
seeing leadership from the governor in
sacramento
as we see literally half a million
californians right now
that have been waiting for their
unemployment checks but yet can't get it
because of the bureaucracies and the
breakdown
in our unemployment department we see
homelessness continue to spiral out of
control
you know all throughout the state and
san diego county we're the only county
where that has actually gone down over
the last two years i'm very proud of the
work that we've done so
these difficult times require leadership
they require bringing people together
and i think that's exactly where this
state needs to go
mayor thanks for joining us this morning
we appreciate it thank you very much